ومن برلمان تركيا على برلمان لادقيقه وخبر
عجيب غريب بصراحه عالم السحر والشعوذه
يعني موجود وبنسمع عنه اخبار عاديه لكن
انه نسمع انه السحر والشعوذه في عالم
السياسه كمان بصراحه هذه غريبه في لاتفيا
في نائبه في البرلمان عينت او عينت ساحره
ومشعوذه شهيره مساعده لها والخبر والصور
انتشروا من هون والجدل طبعا والانتقادات
والهجوم ولعوا كمان من هون الساحره مثل ما
قلت لكم شهيره ومعروفه بلقب الساحره
البيضاء واسمها سانيتيا بيتري وبتعرف عن
حالها بانها معالجه زياده ستايل خاص هيك
بتقول بتقول انه كمان هي بتعالج
بالكريستال الاحجار الكريمه وعندها القدره
على القضاء على الطاقه السلبيه وتحويلها
الى طاقه ايجابيه وشهرتها مش بسبب اعمالها
او عملها هذا لكنها كمان هي نفسها مش
بعيده عن السياسه
سبق وترشحت لا مج لكن ما نجحت في
الانتخابات
وحزبها اللي هو نفس حزب النائب اللي
عينتها لتساعدها الحزب سماها مرشحته مره
لمنصب وزيره الرعايه
تقريبا اما الجدل والانتقادات كلها لا
تعيينها الساحره طلعت بنفسها وردت وقالت
مستغربه الا يمكن للساحره ان تكون في
البرلمان يعني واكدت انها واللي مثلها
مفيدين مهمين جدا في عالم السياسه وانه
كثير من زملائها بيعملوا اصلا في المجال
السياسي وانا بقول اشي كثير والله بتشوف
كثير
[موسيقى]